hello there fambam I'm Greg
come John we're gonna watch from
watchmojo.com the greatest YouTube
channel to have ever existed next to the
Logan Paul channel top ten decade to
finding actors of the 1960s this is a
top reward to your requests from our
patreon page Cameron French this is an
honor of once upon a time in Hollywood
coming out this month
[Music]
it's flowerpower on film and sweet on
the silver screen
Danny DeVito Brando Redford Clint
Eastwood human Nina wasn't seven a
defining male actors / period we've made
our choices based on a combination of
their commercial success their box
office scores their community there and
how that helped set the tone and raise
the standard in Hollywood for the era oh
yeah of course for 10 a cinematic start
Warren Beatty's illustrious film career
began with a role opposite Natalie Wood
in 1961 splendour in the grass
a movie concerned with love critics a
baby's performance baby would star in
many a 60s movie but his overriding
achievement was body imply he produced
and acted in the movie which was
nominated for 10 Academy Awards baby's
box-office power was from this point oh
you gotta say Gene Hackman kind that get
Cargill better number 9 Michael Caine my
name is 1932 reading there Mike Alfie
looks about the same in the model for
Michael P the 60s work is specially
special he was scouted for movie work
following his work on the stage and site
and field the director of Zulu was
particularly drawn to his cockney accent
yes ironically Kane ended up playing an
upper-class
officer in the film but became famous
for more modest roles the womanizing
character Alfie and his part in The
Italian Job confirmed him ask them oh
yes I forgot about
we'll be smashed well I'm glad that
you're enjoying yourselves because Peter
Sellers yeah some dumb career was as
very as his lifestyle suggesting he
played out quite destructive family
relationships off-screen but had us all
laughing hysterically when he was on it
his role as the bumbling Inspector
Clouseau in the Pink Panther is a month
the best remembered a character devised
entirely independently sellers work
during the five weeks of filming has
been compared to the great Charlie
Chaplin dr. Strangelove is another great
Peter Sellers performance for three
that's right
his versatile ability lets Stanley
Kubrick to give him three parts and he
sold everyone the original Mike Myers
universal expose the names Connery Sean
Connery as James Bond the Scottish actor
appeared in five films beginning with
1962 s doctor no you did the right thing
let you pick the wrong moment
he understood the role perfectly and
that's because partly he created it and
he's a real and one liners Fleming's
novels but Connery brought a swagger and
an accent that the writer work to
include in later books he couldn't
however provide everything Connery had
to wear a toupee to play Bond as he'd
begun balding at 21 oh really that fat
one blew right over my bald head
this actors big break came in one of the
biggest films of the decade Lawrence of
Arabia are no tool the first of eight
Oscar nominations for Best Actor though
he never once won he continued rated
white once in the line in winter by no
means a one-trick pony bo O'Toole also
paired up with fellow decade to find our
Peter Sellers in the Woody Allen
scripted comedy what's new pussycat
number five Eastwood the spaghetti
western so-called because of the Italian
directors behind them is an iconic film
genre of the 60s and the one food he
portrayed what the most convincing
anti-heroes ever captured on film see in
this world has two kinds of people my
friend the park was supposedly offered
to Eric Fleming Eastwood's co-star in
the TV Western drama rawhide he turned
it down and Eastwood went on to own it
forever after his name would be
synonymous with the wild wild west
number four Steve McQueen tried to nail
me with a shotgun
Winchester caught a break into the
big-time was thrown Steve McQueen's way
when Frank Sinatra recast the role of
Bill ringa in his movie never so few
parts of McQueen McQueen had lots of
screens
Hollywood has their new it guy I didn't
say come on saying that sometimes you've
been with a breeze or you bring from
their success stream into the 60s with
the Magnificent Seven and the Great
Escape
no one ever brings up Nevada Smith I
love that film a feature most apparent
in number three Sidney Poitier great
movie when trying to achieve success
early on in his acting career Sidney
Poitier struggled because he was
tone-deaf he couldn't meet the
expectation of black performers at the
time because he couldn't sing how
interesting like a notification were
finally followed with acceptance and
excellence in 63 he became the first
black man to receive the Academy Award
for Best Actor for lilies of the field
the commercial peak of his career didn't
come for a further four years however
when guess who's coming to dinner
became an instant closet I can explain
[Laughter]
he's one of the few actors to
successfully carry his movie career from
the 1950s into the 60s 70s and Beyond
eighties in the nineties rebellious
streak entertained with younger
generation after younger generation
roles in movies like the hustler and
hood standout from the early part of
decade Cool Hand Luke earned him his
fourth Oscar nod and a partnership with
Robert Redford garnered him even more
Fame / attorney asked the former in
Butch Cassidy and the Sundance Kid
he saw the 60s out in style Oklahoma
before we unveil our pick four decades
of fighting actor of the 1960s here are
a few honorable mentions now Jim here is
brilliant and witty uses words like a
slam he learned his trade you for making
and Ingersoll really
[Music]
mr. funny he also played foam and we
have like two honorable mentions here
number one heck I guess Brando was like
50 and 70 nevermind that was 62 damn
feels older in To Kill a Mockingbird
released at the height of the civil
rights movement it's both the Guns of
Navarone was another surefire success
and peck filled the boots of a lawyer
once more with the station or Cape Fear
his gentlemanly charm and masculine edge
William our top spot which 1960s actors
do you see as the most iconic every day
be sure to subscribe to watchmojo.com
[Music]
good ol Mark Wahlberg yeah that's
probably the list
it's the grooviest list man it was a
pretty Wilden far-out list baby I guess
it just depends on where you expect
certain people to be ranked but I think
these are the 10 John Wayne or Walter
Matthau probably deserve an honorable
mention cuz John Wayne had at least
three films like I think of that were
pretty big sixties films surely being
one of them and there were barely any
honorable mentions in this video you
think they could have put them in they
could have squeezed a couple more in
there Walter Matthau
you're gonna mention Jack Lemmon I know
you have the apartment also the odd cop
Oh Koppel the oddball we are but Walter
Matthau was in The Odd Couple as well
and you all saw the movie failsafe not a
raid I feel like the 70s maybe a little
bit more available Walter Matthau a lot
of the big actors who were in the 70s
also started getting a jump in the 60s
know Bronson you did a lot of TV in the
60s before he ever I think the fugitive
is one of them have already hopped on to
uh you know doing movies ly doing death
wishes death wish but yeah this is
pretty it's hard to argue with who they
have here all these actors are over
bunch of [ __ ]
mr. list I watched Bonnie and Clyde this
year for the first time I had seen like
the first 40 minutes years ago and and I
just didn't finish it and then a few
months ago I started from the beginning
I think we saw the trailer for the
Highwaymen cent defies me to go but I'm
gonna go back and watch Bonnie and Clyde
I'll watch it it still holds up
incredibly well I you know there's some
date of course there's gonna be some
stuff that feels a little bit dated and
it's a technical approach but for the
most part it's still a you know first
six movie it's still pretty edgy yeah
definitely and I think Warren Beatty's
performance is still as timeless you
know like I think an actor today would
totally give it a different approach but
you can't deny it I got a charming sob
oh yeah well it's fascinating for him
especially I always find him fascinating
for the growth that his career took over
time not only acting but then moving
into the door under that direct yeah
Mickey
Bulwer than really getting involved
heavily behind the camera - instead like
Michael Caine it's crazy Mike okay how
long of a career he took this day you
know he doesn't really headline movies
or people get super excited for it but
he's still like main supporting
characters in so many films people are
glad to see him show up in every
Christopher Nolan movie with Sean
Connery with James Bond I did not know
he wore to pay the kind of ruins
distracts me a little bit from Bond
I heard he mentioned this before for the
car scenes of the Green scream it gets
so hot in there that he wouldn't wear
pants so now I'm just like what the hell
was all naked guy who's okay with
slapping women if they deserve an
interview in which you said not the
worst thing to slap a woman now and then
as I remember you said you don't do it
with a clenched fist it's better to do
it with an open hand yeah yeah I haven't
changed my opinion now when you go back
and watch one of those classic Bond
films that you're gonna be yeah I'm just
gonna be totally distracted by what was
the behind the scenes of this what is
the reality of this moment this video
had a couple little nuggets of trivia
where I was like wow I never would have
guessed cuz his hair he's so suave that
you just don't even think about it yeah
and they said that like his style
actually influenced the books that were
coming out after the movie is including
the accents and everything which I think
it's pretty cool you know a lot of times
authors can be very protective of their
source material and not wanting it to be
influenced by the films but it's cool
one that just goes to show how much of a
defining bond portrayal as Sean Connery
has left to this day yeah man right
behind George Lazenby who really ought
to be on this list you really should get
more recognition
Keter Oh tweeter or tool he did never
one cuz he is an o2 l-- but she hear the
joke joke what can you say he was a
pretty man and he's a great actor man
great actor
early inspiration for dr. strange it's
really cool how Clint Eastwood all these
years later even when he directs films
that he stars in he's still playing the
same guy it's still working out just as
well man he's like I like to think of
Clint Eastwood kind of like bruce
campbell and ash wears just like every
time you check in it's kind of the same
character just a little later on in his
life you know dealing with whatever he's
dealing with now it's like now he just
plays characters they're rougher edges
here because he's so old but they have
more of a heart yeah there's we
grudgingly do the right thing even
though they might not have been that
good a guy earlier in life yeah that's
worth sarcasm but he's always game on
the screen is an antihero
rebellious character and now he's still
just the older version of that now who's
what he is that's what he's involved in
to say that one baseball movie he did
when he tried to do something different
and everyone was like never do that
Quinn watches YouTube he talks to the
Invisible Man on the chair and I seem to
look it up on Google Steve McQueen I'll
know yeah I'll never forget the first
time I saw a bullet especially well my
first Steve McQueen movie was Nevada
Smith I had a weird introduction I guess
into into westerns when I was a kid
because it was Nevada Smith before
Magnificent Seven before the man without
a name trilogy for any of that it was
this random Western starring Steve
McQueen that I loved it and then it's
got me to binge some western films after
that and no one ever brings it up for
some reason and I don't know if it's
like considered a classic yeah I should
see if it's still good I saw when I was
a little kid and I thought it was great
and and that led me down the path of
Steve McQueen films and westerns and
Generals I was on the car tip I was like
in my gear head phase and I was like Oh
classic muscle also you know police
crime stuff well it's cool that like it
to this day he went on to star in the
Vampire Diaries and then he directed 12
years of slave Michael faster yeah
he's still working yeah and you look so
different looks so different he's really
you guys talk about evolution of an
actor yeah this guy right so real
chameleon that Steve McQueen he can be
all kinds of beautiful Sidney Poitier he
is tremendous I got to see in the heat
of the night in the theaters not long
ago that was a really moving experience
cuz that's a great movie but he is just
so lucid in it and like same with like
us who's coming to dinner yeah I like
the nugget of inspiration that they
threw in here about how he was limited
and being able to book it because of the
fact that black actors remain but he had
to be able to sing
yeah then yeah get any work he managed
to break the mold by just beating him in
an amazing actor but he can do drama and
comedy pretty damn well I'm in front of
you watching the heat of the night and
guess it's coming to dinner back to that
this is very present the guy can rock a
suit in both and do a great job totally
different yeah and I mean also like what
what odd pressure that must be to you
know be breaking through it's such a
time and leading some of these movies
that are directly commenting on the
state of where the country was at and
stuff like that like for an actor to
carry that on your shoulders to even
just by association that's got it yeah
like I'm not completely familiar with
this whole filmography but there's no
denying the importance of Sidney Poitier
in the film industry as a whole and the
influences played in media and usually
magic to watch be the first black actor
to win an Oscar a time like that that's
pretty crazy and he had a white guy go
up on stage
Brando went up for him anyway moving on
Paul Newman well they've completely left
out the dressing though the dressing
yeah his dressings Newman's Own is
biopic documentary about lifestyle as a
crossdresser you don't remember this no
no I do I always think of him as like a
timeless actor like when they brought
him to this list I was like oh yeah I
guess the 60s would be like a peak but
Paul Newman is like an actor who just
like I associate with just like the Hall
of Fame of cinema in general
my favorite performance of him is in
cars and cars
this is the last live-action movie and I
think was an HBO movie he did with Ed
Harris the one that went to the big
screen was Road to Perdition yes and I
loved his performances like he's so
different than like young charismatic
Paul Newman it's not just cuz he's older
it's like Clint Eastwood gets older and
just plays a more extreme version it
wasn't Paul Newman he he really bought
us all I didn't watch Cool Hand Luke
until about I want to say around the
holidays of last year and I didn't love
the movie as much as people have
probably hyped it up for me all my life
has gotten a lot cooler since then this
is such a cool dude he's a cool dude see
for me growing up with what Paul Newman
it was always a Butch Cassidy or oddly
enough the hudsucker proxy the Coen
Brothers movie where he's like the head
of the the corporation and stuff like
that Paul Newman can really slip into a
lot of different kinds of roles without
you know being the kind of actor to like
do a bunch of transformations and stuff
like that so yeah the emotional range
yeah I put him up there with a talented
caliber of someone like a Pacino or De
Niro and they came onto the scene in 70s
Robert Redford I like based off going
through this list like I guess I get how
this is ranked because Rob reference
career really started like boom sky-high
in the 70s but he came on to the scene
in the 60s of barefoot in the park and
Butch Cassidy the Sundance Kid I feel
like he's still deserve a bit of an
honorable mention honestly yeah I would
say because I mean he's also another one
of those guys who I mean maybe that
wasn't his peak decade but he is clearly
left a huge indentation on cinema and
also the fact that like Sundance comes
directly from that yeah they did
together in the 60s and exact that like
at least a mention seems like it would
have been yes Gregory Peck
Gregory Peck I grew up definitely with
To Kill a Mockingbird I've never see and
Cape Fear back-to-back I've never seen
the original Cape Fear so there we go we
can swap I think tequila Mockingbird is
great though and he's not the only
character that gets a lot of focus in
that movie cuz you're mainly with the
kids but he is such an enchanting figure
in that film especially and and for what
the movie is about it's one of those
classics where you can really still feel
the
a body around in like the significants
and a lot of that comes from his
performance well this was a good list
what other actor from the sixties do you
think belong on there guys comment below
you can subscribe to the reject nation
subscribe to watchmojo.com / rejects
check us on patreon we got plenty of
goodies Tim and I were talking not long
ago and he was telling me who he thinks
should play Wolverine hmm the defining
actors of their twenties this is a very
big place I'm telling you she should
just start a twitch dreams Charlie
Hunnam Isaac and Aaron Paul should be
top candidates to play Wolverine I think
they should all play Wolverine in a
Doctor Parnassus kind of way where like
in different parts of the movie it's
different actors everyone gets a chance
at their casting and then at the end of
the movie people text in their vote and
then that's it then we'll just have one
actor there you go we solve it I want
you guys vote below who you think should
play Wolverine out of these three only
these three